so I'm jealous of like women being able
to drink things that actually taste good
and then y'all actually get the drink
drinks that up they're actually worth
your time this yeah it's crazy
I love whiskey beer I like IPAs yeah
there's a lot of drinks I wouldn't order
if it's in like a smoothie I wouldn't
order it I am a huge Slurpee fan but
then the sec you put some alcohol in it
I'm like get that away from me yeah and
it's always about the glass the shape of
the glass I come home just go say that
there's something about like a whiskey
glass or a brandy glass is just like I
also would like us to address the
coloring of drink there's also places
for it like I could have a blended
margarita it's like sure you're in Cabo
go for it I think anything drink on a
beach works no rule there's no judgment
on a beach y'all think about all that
when you yeah yeah yeah salon I don't
know I just want to hide the glare yeah
are you sure yeah your hair is first
tears if I was to drink this it needs to
be as sunlight cookout or something
that's like maybe close to the water the
more acceptable things become no again I
wouldn't order it like if I were at a
friend's like baby shower and they're
serving this you know yeah I wish I was
like something yeah I don't know what
half of these rules refreshing I kind of
enjoy the sugary rim I kinda do I would
see if the bartender could put in a
different glass call it a cool name
though LD they give me two el Divo yeah
Cosmo thoughts oh how bad I can easily
drink this this is good to me yeah I
don't have any issues with this at all I
see why women go to the bar and order
cosmos now I get it I understand this is
good actually what if they change the
glass yeah I will be all right with sex
on the beach oh that is that's the bad
that's delight this is the greatest
dream ever made you can hide the stem if
you like this if you
I see at the bar like this or like your
hands big enough let me know you came to
see it
what stealing yeah but this is a
delicious drink though we all go to the
beat this is just refreshing I actually
feel refreshed weak man hiding a lot
this is tasty as [ __ ] yeah like every
time I do something that like maybe you
ain't supposed to do that but why not
why does it matter as a man exactly yeah
that's what I'm saying we should be the
first generation of men to order lemon
drops at the bar I was very skeptical I
was very like if I saw another man I'd
be a little judgy after tasting it it's
just kind of like a you do you man if
you were common if a man is confident
and walk around the bar like this and
look at you and be like what I like
ding stay away from my girlfriend